in the game rock paper scissors kenny
expects to win tie and lose with equal
frequency kenny plays rock paper
scissors often but he suspected his own
games were not following that pattern so
he took a random sample of 24 games and
recorded their outcomes here are his
results so out of the 24 games he won
four lost 13 and tied seven times he
wants to use these results to carry out
a chi-squared goodness of fit test to
determine if the distribution of his
outcomes disagrees with an even
distribution what are the values of the
test statistic the chi-squared test
statistic and p-value for kenny's test
so pause this video and see if you can
figure that out
okay so he's essentially just doing a
hypothesis test using the chi-square
statistic because it's a hypothesis
that's thinking about multiple
categories so what would his null
hypothesis be
well his null hypothesis would be that
he has that all the outcomes are equal
probability outcomes
equal
equal probability
and then his alternative hypothesis
would be that his outcomes
have not equal
not
equal
probability remember we assume that the
null hypothesis is true and then
assuming if the null hypothesis is true
the probability of getting a result at
least this extreme is low enough then we
would reject our null hypothesis another
way to think about it is if our p-value
is below a threshold we would reject our
null hypothesis and so what he did
is he took a sample of 24 games so n is
equal to 24 and then this was the data
that he got now before we even calculate
our chi-square statistic and figure out
what's the probability of getting a
chi-square statistic that large or
greater let's make sure we meet the
conditions for inference for a
chi-squared goodness-of-fit test
so you've seen some of them but some of
them are a little bit different
one is the random condition i'll write
them up here the random condition
and that would be that this truly a
random sample of games and it tells us
right here he took a random sample of
his 24 games so we meet that condition
the second condition when we're talking
about chi-squared hypothesis testing is
the large counts
large counts condition and this is an
important one to appreciate this is that
the expected number of each category of
outcomes is at least equal to five now
you might say hey wait wait i only got
four wins or kenny only got four wins
out of his sample of 24 but that does
not violate the large counts condition
remember what is the expected number of
wins losses and ties well if you we're
assuming the null hypothesis where the
outcomes have equal probability so the
expected
the expected i could write right over
here it would be that it's one-third
one-third one-third and so one-third of
is 8 8 and 8. that's what kenny would
expect and since because all of these
are at least equal to 5 we meet the
large count condition
and then the last condition is the
independence condition
if we aren't sampling with replacement
then we just have to feel good that our
sample size is no more than 10 percent
of the population and he can definitely
play more than 240 games in his life so
we would assume that we meet that
condition as well
and so with that out of the way we can
actually calculate our chi-squared
statistic and try to make some inference
based on it and so let's see our chi
squared statistic
is going to be equal to so for each
category it's going to be the difference
between the expected and what he got in
that sample squared divided by the
expected so the first category is winds
so that's going to be 4 minus 8 4 minus
8 squared over an expected number of
winds of 8
plus losses so that's 13
minus 8.
13 is how many he got how many he lost
minus 8 expected squared over the number
expected
plus
he got seven ties he would have expected
eight squared all of that over eight and
so let's see what is this four minus
eight is negative four you square that
you get sixteen
thirteen minus eight is five you square
that you get 25
7 minus 8 is negative 1 square that you
get 1.
and 16 divided by
8 is going to be 2
25 divided
by 8 is going to be let's see that's 3
and 1 8 so that's 3.125
and then 1 8 is 0.125 0.125
you add these together so let's see it's
going to be 2 plus 3.125 5.125
plus another 0.125 so that's going to be
5.25
so our chi-squared statistic is 5.25
and now to figure out our p-value our
p-value
is going to be equal to the probability
of getting a chi-square statistic
greater than or equal to
5.25 and you could use a chi-squared
table for that
and we always have to think about our
degrees of freedom we have one two three
categories so our degrees of freedom is
going to be one less than that or three
minus one which is two so our degrees of
freedom is going to be equal to two and
that makes sense because you know for a
certain number of games if you know the
number of wins and you know the certain
number of losses you can figure out the
number of ties or if you know any two of
these categories you can always figure
out the third so that's why you have two
degrees of freedom and so let's get out
our chi-squared table so we have 2
degrees of freedom so we are in this row
and where is
5.25 so 5.25
is right over there and so our
probability is going to be between
0.10 and
0.05
so our p value
is going to be greater than 0.05
and less than 0.10
and so for example if ahead of time and
he should have done this ahead of time
he set a significance level of five
percent and our p value here is greater
than five percent which we just saw he
would fail to reject in this situation
the null hypothesis but they're not
asking us that here
all they're asking us is what is our
chi-squared value and what range is our
p-value in well let's see 5.25 are both
of these values and we saw we got a
p-value between 5 and 10
so it is choice a right over there